these are the men accused of setting a
23 year old woman on fire after she
dared to testify against those accused
of her rape
she suffered burns to 95 percent of her
body later dying from her injuries in
hospital the case will be heard in a
fast-track court but it's too late for
her now her family are demanding justice
and for it to be swift yoga sir Carmody
circle Cuevas Arcaro
period SMR ever see a man marry beneath
the knee a man named William vigils have
been held for the young woman
amid outraged and shocked at the sheer
brutality of the attack it's just the
latest in a series of violent incidents
against women
four men were shot by police earlier
this week near Hyderabad after allegedly
raping and murdering a 26 year old woman
and then burning her body to get rid of
the evidence
we need the world to listen up and start
you know speaking up as allies with us I
in a fight to protect the rights that we
have fought for and gained with such
difficulty over the decades in India
here India is battling to deal with
cases of sexual violence against women
even though the punishments for crime
against women have been toughened up and
fast-track courts established to try
such cases the conviction rate remains
low and the wheels of justice slow to
turn never Lazarus Sky News Delhi